all right there are a lot of questions
surrounding hospice care i spoke to a
southwest medical doctor to talk
facts and myths about the service check
it out we're breaking down the facts and
myths of hospice care now first and
foremost let's
define hospice for people who don't know
sure
so hospice is a level of care that's
provided for individuals
who have life-limiting illness and
either the illness can't be treated
anymore that the treatments are failing
or a person says
i don't want to go through these
treatments anymore so the chemotherapy
for their cancer is making them sicker
than
the cancer would and they say you know
what i want comfort care
i don't want to spend my time in
doctor's offices or pharmacies i want
the care to come to me
and uh medicare and medicaid and
insurances
cover that well sure debunking i guess
you could say
yeah the first question here is is
hospice actually a place
people have to go no in fact about 98
of our patients receive care in the home
hospice used to be a place for people to
go
but now the care goes to patients
wherever they live
so whether it's an assisted living or
their own home or an apartment
group home we take
the medical care the medications the
equipment the patient needs for comfort
and safety
all to them is hospice care expensive
so hospice care is covered almost all of
the time
by medicare or medicaid and private
insurances also
cover hospice care so there is a lot of
expense
in providing hospice care but it's not
paid by the patient
how long can someone be in hospice care
if someone
is living at six months and at every
certification opportunity
after that and they still meet the
criteria
or eligibility criteria for hospice they
stay in hospice care
so people sometimes think there's a time
limit or an expiration date
on the hospice services or the patient's
life and that's not true
right and is hospice care just for
cancer patients
no okay so we actually take care of
patients with a
with an incredibly broad array of
diseases
probably the most common ones are cancer
heart disease and lung disease
is hospice just medication the hospice
will provide
medications to continue to manage
but not cure the patient's disease that
qualifies them for our care
and also all of the medications to keep
a patient comfortable
but hospice also provides equipment for
a patient's safety and well-being
we provide social work spiritual care
for both patient
and family and once you decide on
hospice can you go back off of it
yes and if a person does pass away does
the care and support
in the care and support doesn't end
so the bereaved as we call them the
people left behind are eligible for our
bereavement services
great information for more on southwest
medical hospice care call 702-877-5199
or just visit
smalv.com we'll be right back